Уперше уряд Німеччини оприлюднив перелік матеріальних засобів та зброї,
яку готують до відправки в Україну або яка вже перебуває на передовій.
Крім бронежилетів та наметів у списку вказані й більш вагомі речі.
Зокрема, 54 бронетранспортери M113 з озброєнням,
30 зенітних самохідних установок "Гепард" і близько 6000 одиниць боєприпасів до них,
зенітно-ракетний комплекс IRIS-T SLM,
радіолокаційна станція COBRA,
3 реактивні системи залпового вогню MARS із боєзапасом та багато іншого.
Що саме вже передано чи коли саме надійде в Україну, не уточнюється з міркувань безпеки.
Втім, міністр оборони України Олексій Резніков у соцмережах вже повідомив
про "поповнення першими самохідними артилерійськими установками Panzerhaubitze2000".
Після цього й Німеччина підтвердила завершення доставки гаубиць в Україну.
У німецькому списку поставлених озброєнь зазначено 7 самохідних артилерійських установок Panzerhaubitze2000.
За даними джерел DW в Міноборони України, гаубиці "обкатуються" на одному з українських полігонів.
Реєстр військової підтримки України регулярно оновлюватиметься.
Таким чином офіційний Берлін вирішив наблизити порядок публікації військової допомоги
до практики найближчих союзників ФРН, зокрема США.
До переліку входять постачання зі складів збройних сил Німеччини,
а також продукція німецької військової промисловості.
Це фінансується в рамках ініціативи уряду з надання допомоги для забезпечення безпеки іноземних партнерів.
Раніше обсяг коштів, виділених на цю ініціативу на поточний рік, було збільшено до 2 мільярдів євро.
Додаткові засоби призначені насамперед для України.
Україна має бути здатною захиститися від цієї агресії.
Саме тому ми надаємо дуже суттєву фінансову та гуманітарну допомогу Україні.
Саме тому ми постачаємо Україні зброю - багато з якої, до речі, постачається завдяки нашій тісній співпраці
з німецькими зброярськими компаніями.
І тому ми діємо проти Росії безпрецедентно твердими санкціями. Санкціями, що працюють.
Так, ці санкції також шкодять нам, вони шкодять нашим компаніям. Але вони потрібні.
По-друге, цілком очевидно, що ми продовжуватимемо підтримувати Україну, зокрема і зброєю.
І ми продовжуватимемо це робити доти, доки Україна потребуватиме нашої підтримки.
Для того, щоб звільнити окуповані російськими загарбниками території, Україні потрібно значно більше таких озброєнь.
Адже запаси зброї та боєприпасів в ЗСУ вичерпуються, тож українські командири побоюються,
що поступ ЗСУ може сповільнитися, зупинитися або взагалі доведеться відступати.
Віктор із своїми бойовими товаришами зараз далеко від лінії фронту.
Коли розпочалася війна, всі вони працювали за кордоном.
Але вирішили повернутися в Україну з Польщі та Німеччини, щоб захищати свою землю.
Віктор був вражений, коли побачив, що з часів його служби в армії СРСР в українській армії мало що змінилося.
Ну, стара, стара техніка. Гусениці розтягуються, по обладнанню клин затвора застарів. Є нюанси.
Стара техніка вже, як машина. Яка може бути машина 74-го року.
Повністю замінити стару техніку більш новою та потужною поки що неможливо.
Тому продовжувати бойові дії із колишнім темпом та інтенсивністю українським військовим нині проблематично.
За словами співрозмовників, запаси радянських боєприпасів майже вичерпані,
а снаряди західного виробництва не підходять.
Через постійні ракетні удари РФ виробництво зброї в Україні неможливе.
Отже, українцям, схоже, доводиться тягнути час в очікуванні постачання військової техніки від країн-партнерів.
27 числа черги стояли у військкоматах, черги людей!
Просто їх не беруть реально. Вони їдуть, їх привозять назад,
бо не потрібно стільки людей, бо нема зброї, нема чим озброїти.
За словами Віктора, постачати важке озброєння Україні в інтересах самої Європи.
Він не може збагнути, чому західні партнери тягнуть з цим.
Ми робимо зараз роботу за всю Європу.
Путін не зупиниться на Україні. Він піде в Польщу, Прибалтику, він це нахабно заявляє.
Людина, як то кажуть, амбіційна. На своїх амбіціях не знає вже, що робити.
Варто нагадати, що до початку війни канцлер ФРН відмовлявся надавати Україні зброю.
Після того, як Росія напала на Україну 24 лютого, Олаф Шольц змінив риторику
і пообіцяв надати зброю, але процес затягувався.
Згодом Київ звернувся із запитом про постачання важких озброєнь,
і лише недавно німецький уряд зняв заперечення і з цього приводу.
Тепер, як прогнозують експерти, вагань Берліна - давати зброю чи ні - вже не буде.
А можливі затримки можуть бути пов'язані лише з технічними, а не політичними причинами.